what's way cooler than 2009 or 2011 is  the world is ready to understand the  biggest truth which is brand is built in  Social through scaled relevance to many  more consumer segmentations than  television and programmatic digital has  been able to afford us and that the  creative variable to put into those  pipes and a modern comms plan not based  on Impressions and grps is required and  that is an atomic bomb to what we've  been taught for the last 40 years and I  believe that I am stunned by how many  CMOS and more importantly CEOs of these  companies are starting to get to that  realization and that is going to be the  great reset of this industry I think of  the next decade  foreign